[Music]
this is missing the arts in a Surrey and
the eel in music but how is he running
his sound system on blood the beetle has
created a set of batteries which he uses
to power his art installation using his
own blood it took a whole 18 months to
collect a gallon or 4.5 liters that's an
entire body's worth of blood and this is
what he's put into his battery
containers batteries contain two
electrodes a cathode and an anode he's
using aluminium electrode and a copper
electrode however for the battery to
work we need an electrolyte that will
allow charge to travel between the two
rods and this is in the form of Vito's
blood chemicals present in blood can
gain or lose an electron this leaves
them as a charged species however the
electrons don't travel through the blood
instead they take the path of least
resistance which is up value meaning
electrode very wire and back into the
copper electrode this is basically what
electricity is the movement of electrons
and this generates enough of a current
of power vital speaker for the creepiest
composition since psycho
you